hello everyone and welcome to a really
really wild game from the 2012
world blitz championship between magnus
carlson and temur rajab now
uh if you're wondering why i'm showing
again from 2012 between these two
gentlemen
uh well i was just you know doing my own
thing uh
you know checking out twitter preparing
uh to do a video on the morphe saga and
i saw this article
uh by chess 24 where they mentioned uh
something
very very interesting now they mentioned
that magnus carlsen has made an
appearance on the norwegian
comedian morton rams podcast article to
which will be in the description below
to the chess 24 article where you can
find out more about it and
where he uh spoke a little bit about
what happened there
now he said that well he didn't really
have a good start he finished second in
the rapid championship and then he had a
bad start in day one it's not it wasn't
really all that bad it was bad for his
standards as
he wasn't the world champion yet but he
was the number one
uh rated player in the world and then he
also didn't really like his start uh on
day two of the
world blitz championship and then he
says uh he went to his room he opened
the mini bar and he opened up uh he
opened the bottle of russian or
kazakh vodka and he drank as much as he
could in 15 minutes now i know that's
not an exact
measure of uh you know uh of anything
uh as much as you can drink in 15
minutes so it could be anything from
uh you know very little to an entire
bottle i guess
but it is very interesting as uh as
you'll see in the article if you click
on it carlson mentions that when he
returned
uh to the playing hall people were
watching
him staring at him and wondering why he
was so so joyful why he wasn't
worried like he was before as a uh you
know everyone was uh
really worried it was the last day of
the world blitz championship
and the entire event and of course
everyone uh was very
very nervous except magnus and then even
though we don't know how much he rank
uh he started playing and he started
winning not only winning he won
eight games in a row and uh this is one
one of the games i'm going to show you
uh that he played i'm not saying he won
this one i'm just saying
at some point he won eight game games in
a row and it's very interesting that
uh he started this game with uh well
first i'm going to show you as we do
have one photo from this event there you
have it
i don't know if it's from this exact
game but he does have the white pieces
and he does look like he just came back
from his hotel room
uh so let's just imagine uh rajab now
joins him at the table and the magnus
opens the game with none other than a4
the so-called preston where
our opening uh named by uh by the not
the body but
uh well uh the the american
master uh or maybe not even master
american just player preston where who
who played it who was known for playing
uncommon openings
and uh it is a weird move to play but
it's a running joke i don't know if it's
a
it's not a running joke but at some
point i think in 2010
uh magnus carlsen mentioned uh a job of
that
it you know chess is becoming a little
bit boring and that you could probably
play a4 against anyone
amongst the the top players and still
win the game and this is uh probably
why he played it uh although it could be
just you know uh
trying trying uh something new as he he
wasn't really playing
uh up to the level that he he can play
uh in the world blitz championship and
in the entire
event so here we have a4 and rajagov
replies with
e5 with e4 by magnus and now we have uh
a
series of moves that basically
transposes uh into the four nights game
with white uh having a four played on
the board so knight to f6 we have knight
to c3
uh knight to c6 and now knight to f3 so
we have the four knights
with a4 being played and this position
has never been reached
in top level play so we're we're gonna
call it that it is as of move four we
have a completely new game
so here uh rajab continues with bishop
to b4 and now comes
bishop to b5 so here yes you are
threatening to kind of weaken the e4
pawn but it's never really a threat
as you know from similar openings so
here uh we have castles by the job of
and the castles
by magnus uh here you could try to go
for captures
in and win the e5 pawn but as it doesn't
work for black it doesn't work for white
either for example b captures knight
captures on e5 your king is still in the
center of the board and you're going to
have
a lot of problems here for example queen
e7 attacks the knight and now it doesn't
really matter
knight knight goes back and now just
captures captures on c3
the captures and queen captures an e4
check and white's uh
well position doesn't really improve if
anything it deteriorates
for example captures captures and either
king captures an e2
or you don't really have any other other
move to play and then bishop a6 check
and black will be very happy with his
position
so here after castles we have castles by
white and
now comes d6 strengthening the e5 pawn
and white does the same we have d3
we have bishop to g4 developing the
bishop pinning the knight
and now knights to e2 sync to the job of
uh okay you can open up my
king side but if you do this it's a
blitz game do you want to face king h1
rook g1 maybe i can
start an attack against your king maybe
bishop to h6 is coming
who knows it's going to be pretty wild
and it's blitz you know
anything can happen so rajab instead
goes for a6
he doesn't wanna uh uh all that uh
crazy of a game uh and magnus traits
here on c6 we have captures captures and
now
knight to g3 now the knight is nicely
protected by the queen and
h3 is coming uh we have knights to h5 by
rajab and now
h3 challenging the bishop here uh and
here rajab of trades uh we have captures
on g3
f captures and g3 and now he goes back
and uh
now what our java did here is that uh he
he saved his bishop pair and now he has
a bishop here against a bishop and the
knight so
if he can use this to his advantage it
should be should be great for black
however
magnus doesn't want to meet f5 and he
plays g4
the g pawns are doubled so it does make
sense to push it and also you now have
complete control of the f5 square
at some point maybe you can bring the
queen to this diagonal for the moment
you can't as the bishop guard z1 but at
some point maybe knight can come to h4
and then you will have a very nice
outpost on f5
or maybe black will have to weaken the
king's side even further by playing g6
so here
bishop c5 checked by rajab of king to h1
and queen to e7 developing the queen
connecting rooks and
making preparations to execute the d5 as
the e5 pawn is now
nicely protected so queen e1 the bishop
no longer
guards uh not the death square but the
e1 square and now ideas like knight h4
to f5
are possible uh we have f6
uh now saying that okay we're gonna
we're gonna strengthen the center even
further
d5 is coming and here knight to h4
magnus just continues as planned
and rajabov doesn't like the idea of
knight to f5 so he prevents it further
with
g6 now the df5 square is guarded and
magnus continues with bishop to h6 as
uh josh wadeskin would say if you've
ever seen any of his
videos on chess master you have to use
the square
left behind so bishop to h6 now as the
g6 was played
attacking the rook on f8 and here we
have rook to f7
and now magnus continues with rook to b1
preparing to further expand on the king
side
maybe with b4 and so on so here we have
bishop to b6
uh probably a waiting move he doesn't
want to meet b4 with tempo
so he goes bishop to b6 uh although d5
was a possibility here as uh he did
spend a lot of time preparing it so
bishop back to b6
and now magnus just plays the the com b3
move
giving rajab of the move and here uh he
uh starts again with uh not starts again
but here he goes d5
magnus could have gone for a different
idea maybe a5 and then if he goes back
bishop c5 b4 and then go back
but magnus doesn't want to rush anything
he says okay you can keep her bishop
there
instead i'm just going to play b3 and
now a job of strikes in the center
with d5 uh with knight back to f3
uh and now comes rook to e8 bringing the
rook into the game
at some point g5 might be played keeping
that bishop stuck on h6 but magnus isn't
worried
uh first arjaba brings the rook over to
e8 and now
queen to g3 ah the knight has moved now
you
have options of playing h4h5 bust open
the king side and uh start an attack
against the black king so here we have
bishop the c5
again uh seems to be another waiting
move by the job of end
rook b to e1 uh and here d
captures on e4 again g5 was an option
here
as it uh does uh does kind of trap this
bishop
over here on h6 but rajab waits with
that move so first he captures on e for
once
d captures and now bishop back to d6
uh now probably making preparation uh
at some point either execute f5 uh or to
trap the bishop in with the g5 so here
magnus not worried it goes a rook to e2
and now we have
c5 by our job uh we have knight to d2 he
doesn't want to allow c4 because rajav
has doubled c pawns if c4 is played
uh then you can get rid of one of your
uh double pawns and
well magnus just prevents displays
knight to d2 prepares knight to c4 which
will put pressure on the bishop here but
also you might have some ideas of
remaneuvering the knight to let's say
over to d5
so here bishop to e6 again prepares c4
and here queen to d3 magnus again
guards the d the c4 square uh and now
uh here magnus also attacks the a6 pawn
but
uh rajab says uh we're gonna allow you
to capture on a6 i'm gonna try and trap
the bishop now
even though you could defend it with
with a move like bishop to c8 and then
the game continues knight c4 probably
something like this
uh but it's a bliss game you know
anything can happen so we're not going
to dwell on
what could have happened so much
so here g5 trapping the bishop not
allowing it to escape some ideas like
king over here
rook will come here rook to g6 maybe you
can capture the bishop with rook
captures on h6
magnus captures an h on a6 and now king
to h8 and now the question is
how strong is this past pawn and can uh
rajab of trap
well the bishop is trapped but can you
capture it or or is it really trapped
so here we have knight to c4 magnus not
even
uh worried about bishop just yet so
first uh knights to c4 rajab of gladly
trains we have bishop captures
queen captures and now rook to ga the
idea is rook to g6 followed by
rook captures on h6 uh and here
uh will uh here there is only
one good move for magnus and only one
move that wins the game
so even feel free to pause the video
here and try to find this winning idea
while i give you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on spotting this
only move that wins the game uh and for
those of you who just want to enjoy the
show it's
h4 and it's kind of poetic that the only
move that wins the game
is the opposite of a4 how the game
started
but you know that's only if you if if
you enjoy such things
uh the problem is if you play anything
else let's say you play a5 rook g6 just
wins the bishop so you have to play
a h4 h4 is is forced so here h4
uh and of course rajab captures it but
now
uh or if you go for the bishop we also
could show that for example if you go
for the bishop
magnus can just trade and now you don't
really have a good move because uh
there is no move to play you cannot
recapture
uh your position is just terrible and
you you you literally don't have a move
here like
if you capture here then the uh rook on
f7 is hanging rook captures and
you will lose the bishop with check but
it doesn't matter for example king g1
and now the queen is under attack let's
say you go queen e6 uh offer a queen
trade
just rook e2 f2 white is very happy
trading queens he has a rook for a
bishop
and of course the the beautiful past a
pawn so it's a very easy victory
so here instead after this h4 idea
uh we have uh g captures on h4 like we
said
and now g5 by magnus again you can never
capture
as the rook on f7 would hang and you
don't have
all that much to play so rook to g6 has
been played but here
magnus just played rook e to f2 and it
was in this position on move 32 that
tamura java resigned the game as there
was nothing more to be done here so it's
really really a remarkable position
black
really has no moves uh like you could
play a move like c6 or something like
that but
uh it would be pointless uh we could
also show
what happens if you insist on this for
example f captures on g5 just rook
captures on f7 so it doesn't really
work and if you try something like queen
to d7
let's say you just try wasting move then
white easily wins with
just captures on f6 and there's too much
pressure on all of black's pieces
for example if you trade let's say you
capture rook capture sun f6 rook
captures on f6 rook captures and g
captures
there's no defense against rook to g7 uh
all of these squares are covered the
queen is covering this diagonal and
there is no whatever you play any move
you play uh just rook g7 check and
that's it black has to give up the queen
and that's it uh just uh a queen against
the bishop and
also uh there's this past pawn so
very very interesting uh but uh after
this rook e2f2
of course arajabo resigned the game and
uh a brilliant victory for magnus
for magnus carlsen so uh like i said do
check
out the article in the description below
it features all of the games that
magnus won after returning from his
hotel room
and it's just uh i mean it's just a very
crazy story
first i thought it was a joke maybe just
uh you know
i don't know there's no reason for just
24 to post a joke like that
uh since it's not you know april's full
day or anything like that and then i
then i read about it and then it really
sounded very very
uh very true so uh here it is and you
know don't
try this at home or you know don't drink
and go to chess tournaments unless
unless you're like magnus carlsen
elizabeth harmon or
you know a certain magician it will not
work you're just gonna play terrible
chess and
and get wasted uh but you know from time
to time let's say
uh once once every 50 years such a such
a thing occurs
and you know good results happen uh but
yeah
that's uh that's the game i do hope you
enjoyed it once again do check out the
article in the description below
if you want to know more about the story
uh i would like to thank
bjorn brenna scott gonadis ralph waite
luc schmidt and anisha for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it
uh as usual you can check to my previous
videos here thank you for watching
and i will see you soon continuing the
coverage of the morphe saga
checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the chess world or whatever else happens
in the chess world eight years ago
such as such as is the case here uh
so yeah uh thank y'all i will see you
soon and
have an excellent rest of your day